[Musique]
j'ai raté ma vie en afrique lorsque vous
n'êtes pas docteur comptables avocats ou
même professeur ce que le commun des
mortels vous avez raté votre pour
parents ne vous envoie pas à l'école
vous devinez le dire je vais être
designer suivent un styliste vivienne
eco assist
je vais être mannequin ce n'est pas un
métier nouveau en afrique
pourtant j'ai essayé j'essaie de
sucettes au delà qu'ils étaient l'arbre
que je vous laisse j'ai accepté de faire
trois ans en droit
j'ai fait trois années l'administration
générale j'ai eu mes diplômes mais moi
ça ne m'intéressait pas c'est du troll
en français ou pas grand chose pour moi
que moi j'aime pas déçu coup s'est
choisi mes vêtements ça choisi la
chaussure qui vont avec
se marier les couleurs c'est ainsi que
la matière première de qualité
quel bien de chez nous et qu'on n'a pas
maltraiter les artisans qui les ont pas
écoutés j'aime que mon argent c'est
acheter les vêtements qui m'intéressent
qui ont été fabriqués par des personnes
comme vous et moi que tu es fabriqués en
france et en rial non aux africains et à
ceux qui vont les apporter à ses
vêtements l'action a repris dans les
usines dont on ne connaît pas le nom
nous sommes de cette génération là les
slides afin que tout le monde a reconnu
génération internet tout le temps et les
réseaux sociaux ça super ne vous aussi
vous savez que tu internet souvent les
bugs la plus dangereuse pas toujours
l'information
mais quand ce n'est pas un bon nous
sommes nombreux à critiquer à partager a
fait le sale boulot parce que l'iphone
ne décrit quelqu'un mais quand c'est bon
on se calme
personne ne dit rien pour moi la mode
c'est plus qu'une passion c'est devenu
une manière de vie au début j'allais
procès ont malheureusement comme je le
disais mais je me suis rendu compte que
le besoin était la rue des gens avaient
besoin de quelqu'un ou comme une qu'à
leur place de quelqu'un vous montrer au
monde ce qu'il savait faire de quelques
pour raconter leurs histoires sont
traitées ce qu'ils font n'est pas juste
de l'amusement nous n'avons 3 après
c'est tout beau c'est joli ont dit oui
c'est super c'est magnifique ça nous
permet de vous remercie c'est très beau
merci de porter loin le nom de leur pays
mais combien d'entre vous être là où les
aînés
venez donc voir moment donné dit un
design raffiné oil and gas oil question
milieu de la route au travail et hop je
suis prêt à payer pour ça et même si un
équipement la publication nous sommes
peu nombreux à licques et à partager
autant quand on se rencontre nous tous
nous sommes tellement la route nous
interpelle à un point on se rend même
pas compte
avant une sortie cela que je construis
chaque que celle de vincent lenoir était
demandé ce qu'il allait foncer
soit tu me l'avais fait soit vous avez
laissé quelques décidé pour ce qui est
du personnel personne nous sommes ceux
qui me dit que la mode est au coeur de
nos vies mais on ne s'en rend pas compte
mais j'en ai marre
donnez nous un peu la mode africaine ne
bouge pas que nous sommes ce continent
qui sert d'inspiration aux dons mais qui
ne voudrait pas nos artisans travaillent
jour et nuit
ça prend du temps de rester compétitif
dans le haut
ça peut sembler bizarre ça fait sourire
confié mais c'est tout bon travail
derrière
mais pourquoi ensemble nous n'essayons
pas de le faire élever pourquoi nous
n'essayons pas de soutenu nos marques
locales
pourquoi nous n'essayons pas de soutenir
les acteurs de la route de manière à ce
qu'ils puissent porter encore plus haut
notre nom dans cette nous détruisons
façon bien fourni et ça ne devrait pas
ce discours à paris
je pense qu'on s'en fout moi nous
devenir potentielle d'armes ou dans la
rue le croit chez zara plus être
africain le crochet h&m peut être
africain ne plus que là où cela il
faudrait déjà que nous comprenions canal
a acheté le vêtement crée pas un de nos
confrères on ne fait pas que l'amplifier
nous pourrons nous contribuons également
à élever des entreprises à élever notre
continent aux yeux du monde à chaque
fois nous créions les pièces les plus
avant gardistes
maintenant il ya les récupère et passe
du vernis dessus et parce nous demandent
pourquoi outre monsieur était un plaisir
de société outils actuellement qui peut
nous permettre d'étendre notre bois de
lever encore plus notre voix de moins
que qu'on a beaucoup d'insistance que
nos artisans du talent que nous acteurs
nos mannequins notre designer non mais
quand partisme un travail énorme ici
mais non en afrique quand il fait ses
liens on ne dit jamais venu
on encourage pas ou quand jeanne
instaure environ et d'un photon valverde
indicatif
ça coûte moins cher la qualité a un prix
plutôt je crois qu'on s'invente dont le
fort je crois qu'en essayant un tout
petit peu d'être plus attentifs aux
messages aux publications ou à des
personnes qui prennent le temps nous
raconter leur histoire d' humaniser ses
acteurs de la route de montrer à quel
point ce que le travail est important de
montrer a atteint tout neuf pièces sont
uniques
sinon avant gardiste nous pouvons la
soutenir également ces partages 1 s'est
produit un simple life sale ou
tenir le coup et un créatif c'est énorme
bien lancé ma vie vient cet artiste est
à refaire là je vais plus récents
[Applaudissements]